this is the end my friend if season 3 of
Star Trek Picard has you ready to engage
in similar shows here are five more like
this that you've gotta check out next
the third and final season of Star Trek
Picard is a certified fresh hit once
again you heard that right and along
with more Star Trek and other great
sci-fi shows this will be your number
one as we boldly go where some have gone
before I need you
all of you
we're with you
always engage starting with our brand
new pick Star Trek Strange New World now
this is actually a spin-off from the
Star Trek Discovery series and it
follows Captain Kirk's predecessor
Captain Christopher Pike as he navigates
the Enterprise in the decade leading up
to the original series I love a good
prequel and now with a 99 certified
fresh first season under its belt it's
clear that critics are totally on board
and the consensus gives praise for
recapturing the sense of boundless
discovery that Define The franchise's
Roots it basically sounds like any
Trucker's dream or a trekkie's dream if
you're one of those a second season of
this emmy-nominated show is in
production and in the meantime you'll
need about nine hours and Paramount plus
to check out the first season and when
you're done you can call it strange old
worlds let's show them what you got
our throwback pick takes us back to the
60s which is super groovy with the
original Star Trek series and sure it's
a bit obvious but it's also a must
whether you have seen it or not I mean
considered ahead of its time on many
levels it ran from 66 to 69 and it gave
us some pretty iconic characters
ultimately creating a franchise that has
lived long and done pretty well now Star
Trek has an overall fresh score of 80
for the series and if you're not sure
about heading back this far for a show
the consensus from critics reminds us
that it quote may look dated but it's
gadgetry and solid storytelling solidify
its place as one of Pop culture's most
enduring franchises enough said you'll
need about 66 hours to watch all three
seasons and who knows maybe this will
lead you to a place where you say that
Star Trek is better than Star Wars I
mean we love a good debate These Are the
Voyages of the Starship Enterprise
its five-year mission to explore strange
new worlds
to seek out new life and new
civilizations
to boldly go where no man has gone
before next up is our audience pick
thank you friends and that is Battlestar
Galactica this reimagining of the 70s
Show ran from 2004 to 2009. it was
created by Ronald D Moore who had
previously worked on three different
Star Trek series and also went on to
create the series Outlander so he knows
what's up in other words this Edward
James Olmos LED show earned 19 Emmy Noms
and three wins and Not only was it a hit
with fans critics loved it too calling
it quote a captivating combination of
riveting political drama and science
fiction I mean politics and sci-fi it is
a beautiful combination my friends you
can watch all 74 episodes in just over
54 hours on peacock and the whole time
maybe you'll wonder is it Battlestar
Galactica an awesome name for a band too
or maybe that's just me
is over we lost
in people left we leave this solar
system and we don't look back
jump and our editor's pick this week is
the Orville so this sci-fi dramedy was
created by Seth MacFarlane and it set
400 years in the future on an
exploratory ship that is facing both
Intergalactic and everyday life problems
I mean aren't we all the series has a
strong cast led by McFarlane along with
Adrian Palicki and it carries decent
Tomato Meter and audience scores for its
three-season run and critics call the
Orville fun focused and surprisingly
thoughtful you're looking at about 26
hours of bench time for this series but
in space time that's like a fraction of
a light year or something right that's
nothing I have wanted to serve on an
exploratory vessel you're nobody's first
choice for this job but we have 3 000
ships to staff and we need captains can
I have one of these mints those are
marbles
and finally our certified fresh pick
this week is Amazon's the expanse this
one is set in a not so distant future
where humanity is colonized the solar
system and clearly fans couldn't get
enough considering that they campaigned
to save the show after it was canceled
by Sci-fi channel with six very fresh
Seasons critics like the expanse because
it quote Blends sci-fi elements and
detective Noir into a visually
compelling hole you're gonna need nearly
62 hours to get through this one but if
you take it one hour at a time it'll
only take you 62 hours you're welcome
one people
with a shared purpose
we will face the unknown together
well I'm pretty sure Jean-Luc would
totally approve of this list you know
it's good be sure to let us know what
you are currently streaming in the
comments and check back here for more
recommendations based on the shows you
love right here on Rotten Tomatoes more
like this
[Music]